welcome welcome to this video playing my
way he's going oops the one I don't want
to play the Budapest again it's not that
it is a bad for why do anything but just
to get something else I got the Budapest
against this guy all the time let's see
how he's doing in this and this benoni
type of setup ok going back to a bank Oh
should be 7 mm yeah oh I don't know that
line ok let's play 3p prevent night
before yeah my way this is one of them
frequent opponents don't very often we
get very sharp games he's not a big
theoretical player is playing somewhat
offbeat opening sometimes with his own
ideas and enjoyed leads to chaos quite
often is it's just just like that ok
let's check my kendo bishop deaton what
is he playing that night before self
pinning or what I know it looks strange
but he plays weird stuff sometimes so
it's hard to believe that this could be
any good right but maybe it is so where
do I go d1 or c1 and then maybe it's
playing knight to e for something like
that ok let's let's play the move and
then consider mmm but here I thought
just 93 is good and he has to go back
this cannot be a very successful
operation for wide actually for black am
sorry night back to a 6 then a form that
that should be good for white
curious why is he not just retreating
stem a big problem with 9 a-6 that I
don't see I don't know now black black
cannot really make a piece sacrifice out
of this I cannot believe in that at all
yeah just let me take on before it's
very hard to believe he does it yeah
okay that's that's simply not working
but you have to refute it first okay
where to put the night a four is kind of
off side but probably still don't want
to go all the way back 95 efore should
be pretty convincing before it's also
hanging if he goes AFI that playy for
now come on that's not going to work
right so really hard to believe he only
has two pawns for them for the piece at
the moment is three but I'm getting
getting see form okay take here oh yeah
let's take here take see form he cannot
grab eform because of Bishop f7 well
let's say he can but it's nothing
particularly convincing this should be
for Bishop at seven for the 95 tactic
and key point is that he has a victim
he's a very far behind in development so
Queenie to covering E 4
okay Bishop a six maybe try to treat
this a trading is not the main point I
want and they want a 52 I want to have
prevented a five Bishop here 94 95 95 95
it's not a bad move if I can take c6 it
would be nice Bishop f6 I have night c4
and then e 5 okay yeah of course i'll
take and now i have a great position on
CL for this bishop okay that's Kurt and
summer resign yeah yeah that was an
opening disaster assembly yeah they
always write that um yeah I think well
what can you do it I think this is the
kind of dubious check to getting getting
for this self pin this is hard to
believe that this should be any good
what I don't get is ok I went here he
takes Teague's why is night a six so
terrible I mean okay why does better the
debts it's pretty clear but why it is so
terrible that he and sacrificed appease
deform ok it is it is bad right i takes
e4 and night on a six I'm just pushing
through with a five the problem is that
let's say he goes away with the Queen
that it's hard to avoid yeah let's say
he goes back I'm taking and he cannot
play d 6 because of Bishop 86 Queen 84
and what exactly how is he developing
ever hear I've got everything out just
castles and I'm going if I that's really
bad yeah as I said I think the Queen a
five night before ideas not really on he
can maybe do this which is kind of
strange looking but this is certainly
playable I mean not not going to be
killed as quickly as the game here it's
very difficult you lose all that time or
you give up a piece which is maybe then
relatively speaking best but it simply
it's simply never enough yeah and an
important point is he cannot grab this
pawn shop because of bishop at seven
maybe also 95 I'm not sure this might
also be pretty good I mean I have any
peace out and here he doesn't know him
yeah Bishop f6 was an alternative but I
can take on c6 or i can t play Knight c4
it's both both pretty good than a five
yeah it's really just the material okay
well thanks for watching